this is the coca plant in its humble
form it's a great cash crop for tea and
medicinal purposes but it's pretty
useless as a profitable drug because the
cocaine content is just so low so to
make one kilogram of cocaine to sell in
the US you need around 350 kilograms of
dreaded coca leaves which would cost
around three hundred eighty five dollars
from there you dry out these leaves even
more so that it weighs more like 300
kilograms then comes the fun part
extracting all that delicious cocaine
out of those leaves you do this by
finely chopping up the dried leaves and
mixing in some very healthy chemicals
like cement and fertilizer and gasoline
you then filter out all the remaining
plant matter and do your best to remove
all those chemicals not a super big
priority though
boiled the remainder down and you're
left with around one kilogram of damp
cream color pastes known as cocaine base
all you got to do for the last step is
to mix the paste with some kind of
solvent like acetone with hydrochloric
acid filter it dry it and then you're
left with one kilogram of beautiful
snorty Bowl cocaine powder sells out for
eight hundred dollars in Colombia and
that kilogram begins its long journey
down the cocaine supply chain by the
time its exported out of Colombia two
traffickers is worth around two thousand
two hundred dollars then it's time for
the traffickers to work their magic
they'll load it up into planes sneak it
across border crossings mug lit through
tunnels basically they'll do whatever it
takes to get it in put it into markets
like the US once they do the value of
that kilogram jumps up to around
fourteen thousand five hundred dollars
not bad but just because you got it into
the country doesn't mean you're done yet
because now it's time for that kilogram
to climb down the ranks to eventually
get to our loyal customers and keep in
mind at each stage handlers will usually
cut the cocaine with other substances to
make the product go further that's still
our shot the next stop is to the
mid-level dealer which jacks up the
price to around nineteen thousand five
hundred dollars and finally the
mid-level dealers then distribute to
their street-level dealers who then sell
it to our happy customers and after all
the cutting die
and marking up of the product discounted
for what started out as a mere $385 in
trial in the US and South America has
turned into a glorious $122,000 and pure
unadulterated cocaine how because of the
magical economics of drug cartels
[Music]
drug cartels are not like Walmart the
biggest complaint about Walmart is that
they're kind of like a monopoly but a
little bit different a Walmart does have
plenty of competitors but since they're
the biggest and controls so much of the
customer base they're able to dictate
how much they're willing to pay
suppliers for their products because
they're the biggest buyer or in other
words and select Walmart being a
monopoly it's a monopsony whereas a
monopoly is when there's a single seller
in the market only one company selling
oil for example a monopsony is when
there's just a single buyer in the
market to where instead of the customers
getting squeezed
it's these suppliers getting squeezed
drug cartels have the exact same
advantage most of them don't grow their
own drugs they buy drugs from ordinary
poor farmers that are just trying to
make a living
then they package it up all nice and
handle all the distribution to customers
kind of like Walmart since drug cartels
control a piece of territory at gunpoint
a city region or even an entire country
the farmers can't exactly you know shop
around to see which drug cartel will pay
the best price for my coca leaves
since the cartel that owns the territory
is the only buyer this means that if the
farmers have a bad harvest the local
government that's maybe funded by the US
war on drugs cracks down and destroys
half of their farmland or anything else
that can make the farmers cost go up it
doesn't make a single difference to the
drug cartels since they control the
price they're able to keep their cost
down even when the farmers cost go up
and the farmers will always have to suck
it up and take what's offered
most retail businesses sell their
products with a brown attend to 100%
markup from the wholesale price and as
we've already seen markups and the drug
business are a little bit more steep
than that instead of just a 10 to 100
percent markup going from $385 and rock
cocoa leaves to around 122 thousand
dollars and street price cocaine it's
more likely thirty thousand percent
markup now of course not all last
prophet because smuggling tons of legal
drugs with all the murdering and bribing
that typically comes along with it can
get pretty pricey but it's still pretty
profitable because drugs are kind of
like the marketers dream since men
started selling products they've devised
better and better ways to make their
products more addictive because the more
addictive a product is the more it will
sell itself just look at how good social
media platforms have gotten Atlus but
what drugs you don't have to worry about
any of that nonsense because drugs are
as addictive as it gets
so obviously starting a drug cartel is
the only logical choice moving forward
but what would that process look like
again the castilian embedding in some
ways the drug trade is the ultimate form
of entrepreneurship one tough part about
the drug trade is as since it's illegal
instead of a traditional market where
anyone can easily set up shop the drug
trade is more of a network market where
a big part of your success is from the
connections you have so how good are you
are making new friends how good are you
at earning the trust of criminal
strangers since there's no world law you
can't just take someone to court or call
the police if they round you so how good
are you at managing relationships
resolving conflicts or better yet are
you able to manage people in a way where
conflicts don't even arise in the first
place
and if someone does purposely stab you
in the back how willing are you to use
violence
because even though violence is usually
generally bad for business and used as a
last resort because they attracts the
wrong attention the more vicious you are
when you need to be a higher chance
you'll succeed in this world and with
all this money on the line drug
traffickers have tried nearly every idea
under the Sun so what innovation can you
bring to the table to outwit authorities
and make more money
Felix Kai Arlo didn't rise to power from
just doing what every other drug lord
did no he not only came up with the idea
to join together all the major cartels
in Mexico into one Federation but he was
actually able to pull it off and get
them to cooperate with each other
El Chapel is the same story when
everyone else is struggling to bring
drugs across the border or over the
border he came up with the innovative
idea to use tunnels to bring drugs under
the border and subsequently became the
most powerful drug lord in the world so
let's say you're able to achieve this
perfect balance between being the most
innovative entrepreneur while being the
most cunning cutthroat mob boss then
it's time to move on to step two
Oh bummer
one of the most cliche sayings in
business is that an organization's
people are its most valuable asset and
in the drug business this is truer than
ever if you want to build a drug Empire
then you're gonna need people
but not just any people people that are
loyal talented that have just the right
criminal background and aren't stupid
want to find suppliers or farmers you'll
have to find and make friends with the
right people want someone to oversee
your operations you have to find the
right person and you have to recruit
these people in secrecy without job
postings while making sure they're not
undercover cops informants or someone
that's gonna stab you in the back later
on like we mentioned earlier once you
find these people you have to be a
master and managing and dealing with
people problems without resorting to
violence right away mix all of this with
the high profit margins of the business
and you'll quickly realize that HR Human
Resources is one of your biggest
bottlenecks and why the best drug
cartels are usually the ones that are
best at managing its people there are a
few ways to tackle this problem a great
place to find people is in prisons in
the eyes of drug cartels prisons are
like ologists they are a godsend
a bunch of people when nothing better
you do all have criminal backgrounds all
don't have a job lined up after their
release in fact prison is how George
Jung and his business partner met that
the movie blow was based off of George
had experience in smuggling cannabis
already and Carlos had connections with
Pablo Escobar in Colombia
while cocaine was still in its infancy
in the US if you're in more police
countries like the US or UK another
great option is to use independent
contractors hire a bunch of freelancers
and have each only do small simple jobs
that are hard to screw up like cogs in a
machine one person to be the courier one
person to pick up the product and
distribute it to dealers one person to
collect the money one person to count
the money and one person to deliver the
money and since everyone is encapsulated
on a need-to-know basis you expose
yourself to less risk in fact a mini
British cartel ran by just two people
had this exact same system running and
was bringing in around 60 million
pounds per year
so let's say you've gotten this far
you're able to strike the perfect
balance between entrepreneur manager and
a force not to be messed with
you found the right suppliers employees
and business is going great now it's
time to scale baby and the way we scale
is much like any other legitimate
business there are a few things we can
do el chapo was notorious for always
being ahead of the authorities and
evading capture a big part of his
success was that locals loved him or at
least they thought they'd be worse off
without him so they always helped him
evade the police this is because El
Chapo and other drug lords are very good
at PR public relations they would leave
thousand dollar tips build churches give
out Christmas gift to kids build housing
for the poor and even provide cheap
loans to businesses so if you're getting
really big and attracting a lot of
unwanted attention
it might be worth investing in PR today
in our globalized economy companies have
the choice to shop around for which
countries will save them the most money
drug cartels are doing the same thing
with countries like Guatemala and
Honduras because the lower the average
income of the country the lower you have
to pay your workers the more corrupt the
politicians the easier it would be to
bribe them to turn a blind eye so once
your organization gets to a certain
scale offshoring might be worth looking
into and the last way the scale that
we're gonna cover is diversification
drugs go out of style like LSD loss can
change like cannabis in some areas so
we're lying on just one drug to smuggle
is very risky you already have
experience in one drug so it's not too
hard to diversify into another drug a
great example of this is heroin coming
back into fashion recently this was
because patients were getting addicted
to oxycontin but they couldn't afford it
so they fall back on the something
cheaper like heroin this is called
vertical diversification another way is
to diversify horizontally into other
crimes like racketeering gun running
human trafficking or whatever your heart
is
again you already have the
infrastructure now it's just a matter of
repurposing it to fit other operations
and if you've gotten this far then it's
time to sit back relax and enjoy all
that ski suite drug Li just remember
don't get high off of your own supply
[Music]
do you like drugs do you like cocaine
well you're sure gonna like this channel
because I make video essays like this
every single week on the most
provocative and interesting stuff in the
world of business so if you enjoyed this
video you want to see more click that
red subscribe button and turn on the
notification bell below because it's
free and the more people watching the
better videos I can make if you want to
support this channel financially check
out some of the products from myself and
my partner's down in the video
description below some of them are free
some of them are paid and all of them
are really good and really helped out in
supporting this channel because you know
I still have to eat and stuff this video
was based on the book narcotics how to
run a drug cartel a very interesting
read and if you want to learn more about
the specifics and like dive deeper into
it I will link that book down below as
well you can follow me on instagram at j
trend io that's gonna wrap it up for
this video
you've been awesome I've been Jake I'll
see you guys in the next one okay call
the police what are we gonna just solve
society's drug problem you're setting
sweeties that we could use the
unsolvable drug problem in our society
to fix the solvable light problem in our
bar absolutely I hear you we're saying
we're gonna do the drugs and then we're
gonna try and fix all the lights